wer ist das
Barbie wahrscheinlich
Barbie Barbie natürlich
ja das ist aber nicht Barbie auch wenn
sie genauso aussieht es ist auch keine
Kopie das ist Lilly die bildlilly hat er
sogar auch einen eigenen Kinofilm ohne
Lilly keine Barbie dies ist die ganze
Geschichte der berühmtesten Puppe der
Welt und sie beginnt in Deutschland
machen uns auf Spurensuche im Axel
Springer Verlag in Berlin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so normalerweise nicht rein das alle
heiligste das unternehmensarchiv und
hier finden wir auch eine unglaubliche
Geschichte über Gewinner und Verlierer
über Vorbilder und Nachahmer auch ein
Wirtschaftskrimi bei dem die einen
Milliarden gewonnen haben und die
anderen so ziemlich leer ausgegangen
sind
die Geschichte ist so verschlungen wie
die Gänge hier im unternehmensarchiv und
alle Fäden laufen zusammen bei Lars
Bruder Keil dem Leiter des Archivs und
ja eigentlich ist es ein Witz aber die
Barbie hätte es gar nicht gegeben ohne
die allererste Ausgabe der Bild-Zeitung
1952 und das auch nur wegen einer Panne
[Musik]
so da haben wir das gute Stück die
ersten Ausgaben der Welt
original original Wahnsinn
24.06.1952 Grenze bei Helmstedt wird
gesichert Churchill genau wie man sieht
der Name Programm ausschließlich Bilder
auf der Seite eins auch auf der
Rückseite
von Axel Springer hier die Seite 2 genau
in dieser Stelle fehlte kurz vor Andruck
fehlte ein Text der Horror schlechthin
und was was tun in dieser kurzen Zeit
und dann ist man auf die Idee gekommen
den Zeichner der Zeitung Reinhard Putin
zu bitten schnell einen Comic Strip zu
zeichnen und hat an diesem ersten Tag
die Lilly die Welt entdeckt also die
Lilly war erfolgreich die blieb dann die
war dann immer auf Seite 2 genau fast 10
Jahre immer an der gleichen Stelle
gab sogar dann ein lili-bildbuch wo auch
viele von diesen Comics da abgebildet
sind sieht man es hier so auch ein
bisschen sexy halt ja zwar nicht junge
Frau und die natürlich auch das Leben
genossen hat und das sieht man eben auch
in den Karikaturen also verschiedenen
Situationen im Alltag natürlich auch im
Büro
versetzen in die Anfang der 50er Jahre
alles ein bisschen Brüder eine Frau hat
zwei Lebensfragen was soll ich anziehen
und was soll ich kochen und ähm da war
diese junge
Selbstständige Frau die auch einen
eigenen Beruf hatte ja ja die stellte
einen vollkommen neues Frauenbild für
die 50er Jahre da ja dann eigene Beruf
verdient ihr eigenes Geld sie pfiff auf
Konventionen und das war gerade in den
50er Jahren für viele bundesdeutsche
Frauen ein Traum diese Art von Leben zu
haben denn viele Frauen in der
Bundesrepublik konnten nicht arbeiten
gehen damals war sogar noch so man
musste einen Ehemann fragen ob man einen
Job aufnehmen darf
[Musik]
drei Jahre nach der Karikatur plötzlich
Bild Lilly in 3D sozusagen als Puppe das
war schon eine eine riesen Sensation es
gab zwei Größen eine normale Größe in
die in dieser Form und dann gab es noch
mal eine Nummer kleiner in Miniatur es
musste ja auch Kleidung genäht und
geschneidert werden da gibt es ja auch
schon das ganze merchandise
erfunden wo man ordentlich Geld
zusätzlich verdient kann also ja
verrückt also es gab ungefähr sagt man
150 Outfits von Bikini bis zum
Pelzmantel Ballkleider
Sommerkleider oder eben auch für die
kältere Jahreszeit dann schon mal Anorak
und es gibt Möbel dazu es gibt Hunde
dazu Schirme so wie wir es eben dann
später auch von der Barbie gelernt haben
und jetzt beginnt der Wirtschaftskrimi
ein Jahr später macht eine gewisse Ruf
Händler aus Los Angeles mit Ihrer
Familie ein europa-urlaub sie ist in der
Schweiz in Luzern geht an einem
Spielwarengeschäft vorbei und plötzlich
wissen wie vom Blitz getroffen wir
können mal schauen was sie da in der
Autobiografie die sie geschrieben hat
später gesagt hat wir waren absolut
fasziniert Barbara so hieß die Tochter
Barbara Barbie und ich konnten uns von
dem Laden gar nicht mehr losreißen die
Lilly Puppe war die Verkörperung einer
Idee die ich meinem Mann elliot und
unseren anderen Mattel
spielzeugdesignern etwa fünf Jahre zuvor
unterbreitet hatte mit den Brüsten der
schmalen Taille den langen zulaufenden
spitz zulaufenden Beinen die ich den
Designern vor all den Jahren mit
Begeisterung beschrieben hatte das
schrieb Ruf Händler die Mitgründerin der
Riesen Spielzeug für Mama Mattel doch
die hatten abgelehnt die Designer und so
und jetzt konnte sie aber einfach zeigen
was sie sich vorgestellt hat und es gibt
Belege darüber dass sie sich diverse
Lilly gucken hat nach Los Angeles
schicken lassen genau sie sie konnte
jetzt praktisch in echt als
echte Puppe zeigen genauso habe ich mir
das vorgestellt ob das wirklich schon
Jahre vorher ihr Plan war das lasse ich
mal dahingestellt aber offensichtlich
gab es eine Idee eine neue Form von
Puppen zu machen ich sagte der früher
gab es nur Puppen in babyform und sie
wollte so ein attraktive Puppen machen
1959 erscheint dann die Barbie in
Amerika auf der Bildfläche und ist
sofort ein riesen Erfolg 350.000
Exemplare werden im ersten Jahr
verkaufen sorry wieder arbeiten also
irgendwann man muss sich ja vorstellen
damals gab es noch kein Internet da
mussten irgendwie Leute mal nach Amerika
reisen und sehen in den Spielzeuge im
moment mal da ist eine Barbie die sieht
aus wie die Lilly und so haben dann die
deutschen Hersteller das irgendwann
überhaupt mitgekriegt und haben
natürlich dann auch versucht etwas
dagegen zu unternehmen da gab es dann
Rechtsstreitigkeiten auch am Ende hat
man sich dann geeinigt
und Mattel hat von den Deutschen die
rechte gekauft an die Lee und zwar für
sage und schreibe 25.000 Dollar damals
sehr viel Geld wenn man das umrechnet in
D-Mark aber man kann sagen ironisch
betrachtet das war so ziemlich das
schlechteste Geschäft was Axel Springer
und vor allem auch die Spielzeug waren
für mein Coburg die rechte abgetreten
hat die getätigt haben Umsatz mit Barbie
allein im vergangenen Jahr 2022 1,5
Milliarden jede Minute erblicken 100
Barbies die Welt und wenn wir jetzt
darüber sprechen das ist ein Barbie Film
gibt dann sehen wir auch da parallel
denn das war hier
1957 also großes Plakat Lilly gesucht
die aka Film Berlin sucht einen Star für
ihren neuen großen Lilly Film und fragt
alle jungen Bild Leserinnen wer möchte
Bild Lilly sein ähm smirna er hält die
große Chance und man sieht dass sie
natürlich genau nach dem Puppen Vorbild
ist sozusagen ausgesucht worden und 1958
erschienen der Film dann also 65 Jahre
vor dem jetzigen Barbie Film der ist
ganz im Pink gehalten der damals war
natürlich ganz in schwarz-weiß und
trotzdem wenn man es mal nebeneinander
schneidet dann sieht man auch da
verblüffende Ähnlichkeiten
[Musik]
das ist hier los wieso starren mich die
Männer so an
man muss sagen man muss Warner Brothers
wünschen dass der neue Barbie Film
vielleicht ein bisschen besser wird als
der Lilly Film damals
[Musik]
das ist also die
verrückte faszinierende spannende
Geschichte von der Barbie und wenn wir
dann daran denken dass eigentlich alles
begonnen hat mit der Panne bei der
ersten Ausgabe der Bild-Zeitung 1952
diese Lücke die musste gefüllt werden
[Musik]